vous propose un gros plan sur jean luc
mélenchon le candidat de la france
insoumise peut-il aspirer les voix de
gauche comme en 2010 cette première
réponse avec flora sauvage jean luc
mélenchon serait-il le seul candidat
capable de capter le vote utile à gauche
créditée de 13% dans les sondages la
présence du chef de la france un soumise
au second tour de la présidentielle est
de plus en plus crédible pardon mais
j'ai au moins ou qui pour le deuxième
tour où à jean luc mélenchon ou madame
le pen ou monsieur zemmour puisque tout
le monde sait que monsieur macron il
sera alors que la gauche par disperser à
l'élection présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon pourrait bénéficier d'un vote
utile chez les électeurs de gauche on
voit qu'un troisième 20 avril est
complètement possible et pour éviter une
troisième élimination de la gauche
vote utile pour jean luc mélenchon mais
le contexte politique a changé ce qui
change beaucoup en 2022 par rapport en
2017 c'est que le seuil de qualification
pour le second tour a beaucoup baissé 1
on était à 20% en 2010 est là on est à
autour de 15% 1 a évidemment les
rapports de force vont bouger mais on
est autour de 15% donc le la possibilité
pour jean luc mélenchon d'atteindre le
deuxième tour c'est d'une vraie
possibilité une présence au second tour
que certains ne voient pas d'un bon oeil
à gauche les sociaux démocrates lui
préfère emmanuel macron ce ne serait pas
utile d'avoir un président qui sortirait
de l'alliance atlantique
ce ne serait pas utile d'avoir un
président qui sortirait progressivement
de l'europe hamon il faut avoir un
président utile pas simplement un vote
utile mais pour les électeurs de gauche
jean luc mélenchon pourrait bien être le
seul rempart contre un duel entre
emmanuel macron et l'extrême droite au
second tour j -30 avant le premier tour
de la présidentielle vous présente mes
invités laure salvaing bonsoir sa
directrice générale de kantar public
roland cayrol politologue directeur
conseil de région magazine corinne lhaïk
bonsoir joints et sa opinion vous
publiez la nuit tombe deux fois co écrit
avec eric mandonnet c'est aux éditions
fayard
il est ici accrue pavant soir laetitia
éditorialiste politique bienvenue à tous
encore une fois je m'appuie sur votre
dernier baromètre alors salvat qui nous
donne en intentions de vote au premier
tour à meymac ans 31% avec une forte
hausse on y reviendra évidemment marine
le pen est à 17 eric zemmour est à 13
avec une baisse assez forte de trois et
demi valérie pécresse 12 % jean-luc
mélenchon 11% -1 point alors quand j'ai
vu le sondage tout à l'heure je vais
être très honnête avec vous je me suis
ça m'arrange pas exactement parce que
nous on était pour n'était sur un
reportage que vous venez de voir et
d'autres sondeurs qui donne plutôt un
jean luc mélenchon en progrès alors
comment vous expliquer quelles tendances
vous voyez alors nous on regarde en
tendance une tendance plus longue ouais
effectivement cette baisse ll et par
rapport à un sondage il ya quinze jours
juste au moment vraiment le jour où la
russie a déclaré la guerre à l'ukraine
donc il était à ce moment là sur une
tendance très augmentation de
progression ils étaient à égalité avec
avec pécresse et même auprès de certains
électeurs vraiment nettement au dessus
des électeurs hésitants qui avait
finalement choisi un moment donné de
basculer vers jean luc mélenchon est là
aujourd'hui on voit plutôt un tassement
d'ailleurs de l'ensemble des candidats y
compris jean luc mélenchon au profit d'
emmanuel macron qui pour le coup se
renforce vraiment dans nos intentions de
vote et dans les fautes en ciel
électoraux aussi c'est à dire qu'il ya
de plus en plus de gens aujourd'hui qui
nous disent il est possible ce n'est pas
certain mais il est possible que je
puisse voter pour emmanuel macron compte
tenu de la situation oui alors ça c'est
intéressant c'est une des particularités
de ce baromètre c'est que vous avez
calculé le potentiel
serial et ceux qui sont déterminés ceux
qui sont hésitants et dans ce groupe d
si tu en sais quoi c'est un français sur
deux c'est 40% des là il ya encore un
tiers des français est aujourd'hui
hésite entre deux ou plusieurs candidats
forts et ça c'est assez déjà étonnant
dans le cadre de cette campagne
électorale on hésite souvent entre deux
candidats mais là c'est plutôt entre
deux trois voire quatre candidats par
exemple à gauche on hésite entre eux
yannick jadot anne hidalgo jean luc
mélenchon et fabien roussel oui on a 8 %
des électeurs qui hésite entre ces
quatre candidats ce qui n'est pas rien
quand même ça va des voix des voix à
prendre qui sont sur la qui sont déjà
engagés donc effectivement ce sondage il
y assez particulier parce qu'il permet
de regarder quelles sont les potentiels
électoraux de chaque candidat par
exemple à gauche aussi ce qu'on voit
c'est que la candidate qui est la plus
rejeter entre entre guillemets celle
pour qui les français nous disent je ne
voterai jamais pour elle on à 67% des
électeurs français qui nous disent je ne
voterai jamais pour anne hidalgo la
selle qui arrive en dernier 2-2 alors on
y reviendra et on va détailler un peu
candidat par candidat je reste quand
même sur la question jean luc mélenchon
roland cayrol est-ce que ça devient on
l'a vu en le sujet un argument de
campagne quoi le le vote utile à gauche
c'est moi c'est vrai ça devient tout à
fait ça on est encore dans le jeu des
plaques tectoniques
il faut pas faire trop de prévisions
parce que ça va encore bouger clairement
et mélenchon il peut espérer refaire le
coup de la dernière fois où c'est dans
les toutes dernières secondes il a fini
par écraser away à bron et s'installer
comme le candidat de la gauche
comme si elle était élue dit c'est
d'ailleurs intéressant parce que son
directeur de campagne de manuel bompard
à parle sans arrêt du fait que la gauche
peut désormais être présente au second
tour et dit la gauche la dernière fois
en une minute il a dit cinq fois à la
gauche or ça fait six ans qu'aucun lit
des rats soumis n'a jamais employé le
mot de gauche ils ont dix fédérations
républicaine unité populaire union
populaire mais la gauche c'est les
autres et c'est ce qu'ils réprouvent
bâle a en ce moment on fait tellement la
chasse aux éventuelles et hésitant et à
ceux qui auraient des valeurs de gauche
que on n'hésite pas à essayer de les
raboter donc c'est une possibilité
je pense en même temps que le les
problèmes d'image personnel qu'a eu jean
luc mélenchon donc ces fameuses gare
avec les pouvoirs publics et que
désormais la guerre en ukraine ne le
servent pas je crois que tout de même il
a depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine essayer de corriger sa position
mais on se souvient quand même de ce
qu'il a dit avant et surtout que depuis
il met en avoir la neutralité de la
france la sortie de l'otan'' autant de
choses qui peuvent quand même fait
résister un certain nombre d'électeurs
de la gauche modérée donc c'est possible
le coût de votre unique ça me paraît pas
le plus probable à vrai dire et korina
qu'est ce que vous pensez effectivement
que ce ne m'aligne mans de jean luc
mélenchon est en train de lui nuit on
peut lui nuire c'est pas un bon
alignement cindy lui être un non
alignement watan alignement parce que il
a par le passé avant même la guerre en
ukraine manifester et soutien à de
nombreuses dictatures et le propos de
françois hollande est là pour le
rappeler et si jean luc mélenchon rêve
d'incarner la gauche il incarne houndété
deux gauches au moins puisque il ya
vraiment deux gauches irréconciliables
et on a vu deux temps de ces deux
gauches s'exprimer tour à tour sur votre
écran à savoir jean luc mélenchon et
françois hollande et ce qui s'est passé
en 2017 c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une
semaine moi je m'en rappelle très
nettement c'était à la mi avril le
premier tour avait lieu le 23 et à la mi
avril on avait quatre candidats qui tous
les cas tu pouvais accéder au second
tour c'est-à-dire macro fils ou
mélenchon et le pen il y avait une
véritable incertitude certains pensé
qu'on pouvait avoir un second tour le
pen mélenchon ça ne s'est pas avéré mais
certainement que jean luc mélenchon rêve
de rééditer cette performance est de
passer la barrière du premier tour pour
figurer au second mais alors là les
sondages ne donne strictement aucun
aucun espoir je parle sous votre
contrôle mais ce que j'ai vu c'est 78
ans 404 qualification et on rappelle on
l'a déjà dit plusieurs fois sur ce
plateau mais c'est intéressant de le
détaillez le seuil de qualification
sera sans doute beaucoup plus bas pour 7
pour cette élection puisque en 2007 il
était à près de 20 % jean-luc mélenchon
et avec 19 points 6 19 58 pour être très
précis il arrivait en quatrième position
exactement là on veut on peut se
qualifier à quoi à 15,16 peut-être bah
oui c'est ça c'est effectivement
beaucoup plus bas que qu'en 2007 et
comme vous le disiez en effet on est
encore à un mois de l'élection et on
peut encore avoir quelques quelques
surprises corrosion parce que sinon une
abstention massive mais exactement quand
vous avez encore un tiers des électeurs
français qui ne savent pas qu'ils
hésitent encore pour guillet voter c'est
énorme en fait des voix lasse et c'est
pour moi l'information principale à
l'heure actuelle c'est c'est ça il ya
des mouvements effectivement chez
mélenchon chez pécresse chez zemmour
aussi on en parlera peut-être vrai mais
il ya des dynamiques de campagne très
clair mais en fait on a quand même
beaucoup aujourd'hui beaucoup de
personnes qui hésitent et puis un des
sujets de campagne aussi qu'ils sont pas
si évident que ça à cerner en fait à
quel est le sujet de préoccupation alors
aujourd'hui c'est l'ukraine mais
derrière ça il n'y a pas que l'ukraine
les français gardent encore des
aspirations dans d'autres domaines et
c'est pour ça je le disais en titre nous
on a vraiment décidé de refaire de la
place à la campagne présidentielle dans
cette émission ce sera au moins un des
débats de l'émission pour c'était le cas
hier ce sera le cas dans les dents les
jours de la semaine prochaine ça nous
semble évidemment très important qui a
séduit maintenant nous devons pas nous
reprocher d'avoir utilisé une image une
photo qui n'était pas à son avantage
vous souvenez la dernière fois oui et là
on lui a retiré 20 ans
comme sage
analyse rapide de l'image signalétique
effectivement les avait reproché une
faute au sol dix ans d'un mélenchon à
jean luc mélenchon agressif alors on
passe on nous le chapitre emmanuel
macron tout de suite dans dans cette
émission avec vous laetitia justement
c'est pas facile de faire campagne
autour d' emmanuel macron parce qu'il a
le goût de la surprise il prévient pas
forcément ses équipes s'exempte pour ces
équipes là pour ses proches c'est pas
facile c'est un euphémisme c'est à dire
qu'ils sont ils apprennent les choses
les mesures en même temps que le public
donc vous imaginez un peu la panique
qu'il y a dans ses rangs exemple avec
son premier déplacement de campagne
lundi à poissy où il annonce une mesure
phare écoutez on doit continuer ce
travail pour que le travail paye mieux
comment on supprimera des impôts qui
reste la redevance télé en fait partie
ces 137 euros environ en moyenne pas
senna aussi cet aveugle c'est cohérent
avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation faut aller au bout
première surprise et alors on en a moins
parlé il ya une deuxième surprise c'est
le chèque alimentaire sa voix pour
contre la précarité alimentaire là en
l'occurrence c'était pour essayer de
contrer les conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine pourquoi on en a moins parlé
parce qu'en fait c'est une mesure qui
est né en ayant en 1900 non 2000 qui a
été repoussée en 21 puis en 22 mais la
question n'est pas là thomas c'est que
en fait c'est 2 annonce était une
surprise pour ses équipes d'ailleurs
qu'on l'a appris par la suite notamment
à la faveur d'un article dans les échos
de cécile cornudet ou ses proches ont
dit ont avoué qu'ils n'étaient pas tenus
au courant de ces mesures que ce n'était
pas dans le programme du candidat pour
son premier déplacement et donc il se
sent dit après ok si tous ces
déplacements sont de fait honneur si à
chaque fois nous découvrons en même
temps que le public ça va être un tout
petit peu compliqué à organiser cette
campagne alors il ya il ya un autre cas
d'école donc là on est dans un peu dans
le temps le goût de la surprise aussi
odieux secret quand il reçoit les
parlementaires lrm septet hier il leur
parle de la réforme des retraites est
juste après face à notre journaliste
hugo lemonnier à ses parlementaires il
avait manifestement reçu la consigne ne
surtout pas parler de logements en 65
ans regarder non non il n'y a pas de
mesures d'âge on n'en est pas du tout là
là là mesures d'âge la mesure la mesure
d'âge se fera en concertation on n'en
est pas là quand vous nous parler de
quelque chose qui est aujourd'hui en
discussion dans un programme qui n'est
pas encore arbitré qui n'a pas encore
été présentée payer il faudra une
réforme des retraites on verra éclore
on verra ça en son temps son temps et
c'est tout les sens aussi du nouveau
pacte démocratique c'est de faire avec
les gens il pas de faire des de décider
tout seul dans un bureau parisien mais
de faire avec l'ensemble des non
seulement l'ensemble des syndicats mais
l'ensemble des 100 vous ferez la
retraite à 65 ans attendez de voir le
programme du candidat avant de commenter
ce que pouvait lire dans la presse le
président de la république annonçait qu
il nous faudrait sauver le régime des
retraites et c'est de cela dont on va
parler aussi avec les français donc non
non non il y aura pas de mesure du tout
sur les retraites il fallait juste
attendre ce matin et les matinales radio
regardez
au titre de l'universalité il faudra
supprimer les principaux régimes
spéciaux au titre de l'équité il nous
faudra veiller à ce que les retraites
complète soit à minima à hauteur de 1100
euros c'est le fruit du travail mais
pour faire tout ça à des faits c'est
l'âge qui doit l'âge de départ l'âge
légal qui doit permettre d'équilibrer
l'ensemble de ce système dans le
programme d' emmanuel macron il y aura
la proposition d'allonger
l'âge de départ à la retraite et donc de
le passer progressivement à 65 ans bon
alors deux méthodes un de style
pour les premiers on ne prévient
personne et pour le deuxième on donne
l'ordre de ne rien dire et on laisse ses
lieutenants annoncé quand même ce qui
était la réforme phare de son premier
quinquennat donc c'est très étrange de
la part du candidat macron de ne pas
prendre dans sa voix cette réforme est
de laisser gabriela talent richard
ferrand est ce que on va avoir encore
cette méthode répéter on ne sait pas en
tout cas dans une dizaine de jours
normalement emmanuel macron doit
présenter son programme et annoncé la
création d'un site internet où toutes
les mesures seront détaillées roland
cayrol c'est une campagne présidentielle
c'est beaucoup une question de rythme et
et de thématiques qui réussit à prendre
la main sur les thématiques on l'a
souvent démontré dans l'ordre dès lors
de précédentes élections là comme les
candidats les autres candidates et
candidats attendent emmanuel macron
depuis des semaines c est ce que c'est
forcément lui qui va donner le rythme
voyez ce que je veux dire je le crois je
le crois je crois qu'en effet ils ont
tellement dit que il boxait dans le vide
et qu'ils avaient besoin d'avoir les
propositions de macron pour pouvoir
boxer contre quelqu'un que oui c'est lui
qui va donner le peu son programme petit
à petit et en fait on l'aura la semaine
prochaine et ça permettra d'avoir un
débat où chacun se positionnera par
rapport aux vraies propositions de
macron en attendant dans toute stratégie
de communication qui se respecte il ya
toujours la terre de stratégie des
ballons d'essai et c'est aussi pardon à
ça que servent les journées c'est ça
c'est un ballon d'essai les retraites
complètement enfin ça fait cinq ans
qu'il est sur le dossier donc si elle ne
sait pas c'est maintenant qu'il est en
campagne c'est maintenant qu'il faut
faire ça et regarder on en parle et ça
pourrait ça ça pourrait ça ça pourrait
aussi être ça et puis les seuls qui sont
macro n'ya là dedans c'est richard
ferrand élite et attal qui a fondu en
même temps il ya sûrement de la mesure
d'âge mais il ya aussi des mesures
d'équité de justice qu voilà et on aura
probablement tout ça dans le programme
définitif corinne lane dans votre livre
la nuit tombe deux fois vous décrivez un
emmanuel macron confrontés au défi de
autorités lui ont manqué où il lui en
manque je ne sais pas alors la crise
actuelle fait ressortir vraiment les
deux côtés d' emmanuel macron autant
dans les crises extérieures il peut
faire valoir ses qualités qui sont hyper
centralisation des pères
présidentialisation hyper implication
personnelle et là dans l'ukraine d'où sa
à plein et ça lui réussit plutôt en
revanche dans les sujets internes et
c'est ce que nous racontons dans notre
livre avait carrément données qui
concernent plutôt toutes les questions
d'insécurité intérieur de lutte contre
l'islamisme et cetera il veut tellement
faire preuve deux en même temps en clair
ménages et des sensibilités diverses
certains diraient la chèvre et le chou
qu'il finit par ne pas décider il est
prisonnier aussi de son propre
tempérament il a besoin de maturer les
sujets pendant très longtemps il a
besoin de lait mâchonner comme il dit on
le voit par exemple sur la loi
séparatisme qui met trois ans avant
d'aboutir on le voit sur les sujets
police justice où il ouvre des chantiers
extrêmement important à la fin du
quinquennat on le voit sur les sujets
comme les violences policières où ils
disent suivant ses interlocuteurs un peu
ce qu'ils ont envie d'entendre et donc
il est prisonnier de ce en même temps
qui par ailleurs peut se pratiquer il
n'est pas interdit mais en matière
d'autorité on peut pas être un indien
avec des plumes et un cowboy avec un
grand chapeau faut que
l'image peut valoir malheureusement
entendre en temps de conflit alors
salvat alors c'est vraiment un élément
peut-être le
la leçon majeure de votre baromètre
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet drapeau
voilà ce boost sur les intentions de
vote où la popularité d'ailleurs les
deux sont liés d'emmanuel macro les deux
en effet effectivement avec une
progression énorme à la fois dans notre
baromètre figaro magazine d'ailleurs un
livre pour le coc qui est réalisée tous
les mois et dans ce baromètre la hep au
cas où on était à 15 jours d'intervalle
c'est vraiment le grand gagnant c'est
lui qui consolide aussi le plus son
électorat c'est à dire qu'on avait pas
mal d'hésitant encore il ya quinze jours
et là est le socle de son électorat et
plus sûr qu'il y a quinze 15 jours c'est
également lui qui récupère pas mal de
deux voix aussi de
zemmour qui était parti qui hésite et de
marine le pen aussi et puis de valérie
pécresse jean que valérie pécresse se
maintient quand maman est plutôt plutôt
stable et puis enfin juste un point sur
sur les retraites peut-être c'est un
sondage qui nous que nous avons sorti
aujourd'hui et ça fait partie quand même
des préoccupations le système des
retraites de ses électeurs de son
électorat plus particulièrement donc
c'est quelque chose aussi il savait
qu'il allait
attirer et satisfaire une personne son
électorat il répondu sans langue de bois
à l'électorat une partie de l'électorat
de droite qui est très soucieux de
l'équilibré des retraites jetair le
merlan cayrol l'uniforme de chefs de
guerre c'est de l'autorité automatique
est ce qu'on peut dire que oui on peut
dire ça et c'est assez classique en
france comme dans tous les pays dès
qu'on est en conflit armé mais il ya une
espèce de regroupement naturel derrière
le chef surtout si le chef était
vraiment en train de chauffer et là on
le voir il est quand même tous les jours
au téléphone avec plus grand du monde il
vient nous en parler à la télé voilà il
si on compare
ce président candidat avec tous les
autres candidats le chaland souvent
qu'ils seront en mesure de faire
président c'est lui et c'est un avantage
aussi les tentatives des ondes les
insérer dans cette posture est forcément
franchement voilà il veut surtout pas
qu'on dise que l'élection est pliée
macro yves surtout pas qu'on dise parce
que il a peur de l'abstention que les jo
soient d'ici se joue et ça j'y vais pas
légitimité moi je crois que les aixois
est plié je crois qu'il n'y a plus
aucune possibilité autre que cela sauf
tsunami après tout l'ukraine il peut y
avoir autre chose mais logiquement les
jeux sont faits
c'est pourtant remarquent ronis c'est
juste parce que je trouve que c'est
dommage que dans une élection aussi
majeure que celle alors que d'accord il
ya des enjeux qui sont les on parle du
nucléaire c'est des enjeux qui nous
engage pas vraiment les 40 prochaines
années je jure que je sais pas combien
40 mois je retire pas seulement il n'y a
pas seulement qu'ils récupèrent une
stature de d'autorité par la guerre il
ya le fait que ce qu'il a enclenchée en
2017 est toujours vrai ils gagnent la
dernière élection présidentielle sur
cette trouvaille qui était pas une
trouvaille pour les sondeurs que tous
leurs rapports se terminer sur la
politique en disant de la majorité des
français en ont marre de cette
opposition stérile entre la gauche et la
droite il faut que les gens sérieux
souhaite autour d'une table et se
mettent d'accord il fait de son thème de
campagne c'est là dessus qu'ils gagnent
et il a 24 24% au premier tour dans 12
viennent de la gauche 12/12 du centre et
de la droite il aurait voulu faire
exprès il n'aurait pas fait mieux et je
crois que ces poutres la continuer à
travailler dire que je crois que et la
droite républicaine et la gauche sociale
démocrate sont dans un état de faillite
réel dans l'opinion française
mais non c'est ce que boxer ce que
beaucoup en terrible c'est ce qu'on voit
pas aujourd'hui dans les études il a
toujours à peu près la même proposition
à
sa responsabilité ce sont davantage des
hommes qui viennent de la droite se
comptent pas beaucoup touché il gagne
aussi la baci compte c'est quand même ce
qui compte c'est la société dans la
société il a gardé ça et c'est un atout
formidable jusqu'à la droite n'a plus de
propositions réelles qui se sépare de
tous les autres et la social démocratie
dans l'ensemble de l'europe allemagne
comprise contrairement à ce que dit la
nisa look le spd a fait le plus mauvais
score de son histoire aux dernières
élections allemandes la social
démocratie a tellement bien réussi sur
notre continent quel à appliquer son
programme elle n'a plus rien à proposer
qu'on vous dit il a gagné il a gagné une
grande victoire idéologique avec le
triomphe de l'europe toutes les idées
qui l'a mise dans son
nom en 2020 aussi avec le plan de
relance européen
faire valider par l'europe deux grandes
idées qui sont des idées françaises qui
défendent est déjà quand il était
secrétaire général adjoint à l'elysée
auprès de françois hollande ils sont 1
la bulle chétif à la mise en commun d'un
budget européen la mutualisation des
risques au niveau de l'europe il le fait
à la faveur de la crise le coc vide mais
il arrive à convaincre angela merkel
dont c'est aussi l'intérêt de faire
cette mutualisation c'est une grande
victoire idéologique et la seconde c'est
l'histoire de ce que nous vivons en ce
moment l'idée d'une défense européenne
l'an dernier le premier plan
d'endettement commun et c'est l'un des
enjeux du sommet de versailles on y
reviendra dans notre second débat tout à
l'heure je voudrais conclure sur cette
idée de défaite drapeau de ralliement au
drapeau là ces ralliements au drame a
été conceptualisée été conceptualisée
c'est l'effet ralliement au drapeau
c'est a été inventé en 1973 donc c'est
relativement récent par un politologue
américain qui s'appelle john muller et
il a montré qu effectivement les drames
subie par une population était corrélé
avec la courbe de popularité du
dirigeant du pays qui subit les drames
et par exemple après les attentats du 11
septembre c'est l'exemple le plus qui
illustre le plus 7 ce concept c'est bush
qui gagne 39 points de popularité et il
atteint 90% d'opinions favorables après
les attentats françois hollande aussi un
gagnera lui 22 points après l'agression
c'est combien de temps ça dure voilà
c'est un sursaut de popularité qu'il est
souvent très éphémère alors combien de
temps ça dure je vous rappelle que le
premier tour et dans un mois est ce que
ça tiens moi on verra bien je voudrais
boucler ce chapitre consacré aux
emmanuel macron par la question d'un
débat avant le premier tour écouter ce
que
xavier bertrand en 10 alors le président
avait déjà refusé de débattre à 12
c'était très clair et donc
l'ancien candidat à l'investiture et
leur sort une idée de son chapeau
l'écoutent je veux bien comprendre que
un débat à 12 c'est certainement pas
facile mais il ya aujourd'hui trois ou
quatre candidats qui peuvent être au
second tour et qui se tiennent
pourquoi ne pas accepter il ya quatre
semaines un débat avec chacun des
candidats monsieur macron contre valérie
pécresse monsieur macron face à monsieur
zemmour face à monsieur mélenchon face à
madame le pen de façon à ce qu'il y ait
cette confrontation d'idées bon ça va
pas durer je pense que dans la
demi-heure qui suivait une réponse
négative roland cayrol dit quoi drôle
d'idée ou alors effectivement il n'y a
pas de débat d'idées parce que ya pas de
débat le grand débat avant le premier
jour je rappelle que les autres
président sortant monsieur exact
de 2017 donc
oui il n'ya jamais eu l'idée parce qu'on
savait que quand il y avait président
sortant il n'était pas question
qu'un président sortant et dans la
mairie pour se colleter d'i-source
personnes qui viennent l'attaqué lui
donc voilà mais comme les français
aiment bien les débats et comme c'est
bien ça qui les intéressent le plus en
politique c'est normal que les opposants
joue là dessus et 10000 fois débat il
faut des débats il faut des débats qui
nous donnent des débats il fuit le débat
mais se fait partout ailleurs si je
police et c'est l'un des éléments vous
avez sondés
ont sondé on avait sondé aussi depuis le
début de la campagne c'est à dire de
quoi ont besoin aussi les français pour
pouvoir décider effectivement ils sont
très très large majorité à dire nous on
veut voir des débats lors des débats
particulière ils ne veulent pas
d'agressivité dans ces débats immunes et
des bas des gens valady des des changes
calme et c'est pas forcément
d'invectivés personnelles forcément
c'est ce qu'ils disent de sondeurs c'est
ce qu'ils disent
regardez mélenchon s'aimer mais
l'annoncé c'est vrai que en tout cas
pour eux il regrette qu'il n'y ait pas
suffisamment de débats d'idées et
suffisamment aussi de thématiques qui
soit débattu dans le débat public on l'a
vu il ya deux jours sur la journée sur
les femmes par exemple et bien par
exemple l'égalité homme-femme plus de
70% des français nous disent aujourd'hui
que on ne débat pas suffisamment de ce
sujet pendant la campagne par exemple
voilà cent des sujets qui ne sont jamais
abordées et il y en a beaucoup est ce
qu'on essaie de faire depuis plusieurs
semaines dans cette émission en dehors
de la noce est évidemment la semaine
dernière et le début de cette semaine
100 % consacrés à l'actualité
ukrainienne et c'était normal alors vous
m'offrez la transition effectivement si
les français veulent des débats il y en
a un ce soir valérie pécresse face à
eric zemmour c'est sur tf1 puis lci est
ce que vous diriez que c'est le combat
de deux essoufflé une certaine façon
dans cette présidentielle ne permettrait
pas d'utiliser mois juin tout le monde
est un peu essoufflée 1 passe d'emmanuel
macron est très loin donc ils doivent
tous beaucoup courir non je trouve que
c'est un débat qui pensent ans pour la
candidate elle prend un risque mais elle
a raison de le prendre de son point de
vue elle peut plutôt gagné elle n'a pas
tellement à perdre eric zemmour devra
faire attention de ne pas être trop
agressif mais présent arrogant de nous
montrer qu'elle est une femme etc
elle peut s'attirer la sympathie d'une
partie de l'électorat de tous ceux qui
n'aiment pas eric eric zemmour donc je
trouve que l a bien fait d'accepter de
son de son point de vue lui je sais pas
trop ce qu'il a à gagner ou à perdre
mais en tout cas je trouve que la fiche
va être intéressant parce qu'en plus sur
le fond il va falloir qu'elle se
démarque des sujets d'eric zemmour et de
la sionisation de sa campagne qu'on a un
petit peu oublié maintenant parce que
tout écraser par l'ukraine mais qui
était quand même très marquante au début
c'est à dire qu'elle était obligée de
faire le grand écart entre la candidate
de gouvernement et finalement proche de
maquereaux calais est la candidate tenu
par le score de ce que tu y as la
primaire de la droite donc là ça va être
intéressant de voir sur les sujets de
fond qui ont les sujets chers à eric
zemmour l'identité française
l'immigration etc qu'elle voit elle fait
entre en compte entre le titre wissam
équipes comptent beaucoup sur ce débat
pour eux c'est stratégique c'est à dire
que c'est un moment de pivot dans
soufflement de leur candidate parce que
ils pensent et ajuster que valérie
pécresse est bonne dans les débats
qu'elle se démarque et que ça peut être
justement pour elle a une façon de
basculer dans une reprise de souffle et
en tout cas voilà une trajectoire plus
ascensionnel laure salvaing eric zemmour
c'est celui qui souffre le plus depuis
le début de la politiquement évidemment
depuis le début de cette guerre en
ukraine parce que voilà tout le monde
ressort sa platine au fini on va dire ça
comme ça oui c'est vrai que dans notre
sondage en effet on voit que celui dont
l'électorat s'effrite le plus c'est eric
zemmour quinze jours après donc l'entrée
en gare de la de la russie je pense que
le débat ce soir va être d'autant plus
important qu'il ya énormément notamment
je reviens sur ce sujet mais de femmes
qui hésitent qui sont très hésitante et
qui sont assez
circonspects dans tours justement
baleri pécresse et eric zemmour et
notamment sur des sujets effectivement
d'immigration d'identité
sur des sujets comme comme celui ci donc
ce soir ça va être importante capoue
valérie pécresse de consolider s'est
saisie temps la
rockhal est ce que bon je rejoins ce que
vous dites peut-être que de toute façon
il fallait qu'elle prenne ce risque
valérie pécresse mais il ya une forme de
légitimation aussi d'eric zemmour en
acceptant un débat comme celui là oui il
y est ça il ya les deux et elle a besoin
elle de montrer qu'elle est dans cette
campagne sur un positionnement qui n'est
pas celui qu'elle a adoptée depuis le
début et c'est je crois trompé de
campagne elle a fait une campagne pour
aller rechercher les voies de zemmour et
de marine le pen alors qu'elle a un
gisement qui lui était indispensable au
premier tour c'est ceux des français
républicain démocrate centriste modéré
droit européen hélas quand même tourné
le dos à tout ça y compris sur l'europe
sortie des discours sur la souveraineté
nationale opposé au cas la construction
de l'europe qui en effet est l ubu
ciotti dans le texte ça c'est quand même
très est là parce que c'est la campagne
l air qui a fait basculer ce sens oui
oui mais l'idée c'est au fait ça quand
on fait une mairie mais après on ouvre
autrement l a pas fait et donc il est
temps peut-être mon avis c'est bien tard
pour le faire et je crois que c'est tout
ce sont en jeu est ce qu'elle peut être
autre chose que ce qu'elle a été
politiquement depuis le début et zemmour
lui
font ce qu il a fait progresser
formidablement il est quand même le seul
qui ait fait cette incroyable campagne
avec cet incroyable succès et sur une
thématique est le seul qui ait pas
l'immigration que mon 10mai telle
hostilité aux musulmans c'est sûr contre
l'islam qu'il ya des gens qui en ont
marre des musulmans qui voudrait qu'il
ait plus de musulmans en france ils sont
aussi violents que lui là dessus et ce à
la salle à aider ce qui l'a le plus
poser le plus problème dans l'opinion
c'est le moment où il lâche complètement
toute compassion ce qu'il dit sur les
enfants handicapés et le fait que
doivent pas être intégrés comme tous les
autres dans les mêmes écoles ça t'a
qu'on a eu immédiatement des réactions
de sondages très mauvaise dans son
propre électorat et puis en effet sur
les réfugiés ukrainien où il essaye
depuis de rétropédaler en expliquant que
si c'est ici s'ils ont des familles
settat et il lui faut montrer que il est
quelqu'un qui a d'abord un programme
présidentiel qui se limitent pas aux
musulmans mais il faut qu'il le rappelle
quand même parce que c'est son fond de
commerce mais il faut en même temps qui
montre qu'il a un minimum de compassion
pour les électeurs français et leurs
problèmes pendant ce temps la marine le
pen qui fait je rappelle sa troisième
campagne présidentielle et c'est je
pense que c'est important dans la
réflexion voilà c'est peut-être aussi le
moyen de faire moins d'erreurs que
d'autres pour qui c'est la première
campagne
alors que la poutine au chili dont je
parlais pour eric zemmour était aussi
pour marine le pen elle ne finance pas
ou moi comment comment vous l'analysez
ça effectivement on le voit sur
différents sujets que ce soit sur
l'ukraine sur la santé sur l'éducation
etc marine le pen elle a quand même un
niveau de crédibilité
alors inférieur à emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron effectivement en termes
de légitimité et de crédibilité il
explose tous les compteurs mais marine
le pen elle se elle se défend pas si mal
mais parce qu'aussi elle a l'expérience
parce que finalement les français ont le
sentiment qu'elle est quand même là
depuis longtemps qu'elle à la pratique
aussi des politiques potentiellement de
certains dirigeants politiques et
caetera et puis c'est pas su lire sur
ces sujets là notamment que ses
électeurs
s'intéressent à sa campagne à sa
candidature on le voit dans le sondage
aussi un ce qui les préoccupe le plus
les électeurs de marine le pen c'est le
coût de la vie et pas l'ukraine en mai
pour les français c'est l'ukraine pour
les électeurs de marine le pen c'est le
coût de la vie donc en fait tant qu'elle
va rester aussi sur cette thématique la
supercinq à l'arrêt sur ces thématiques
à elle et à aussi l'oeil sur les
sondages on cale sait très bien les
s'agit de connecter ses sujets de
pouvoir d'achat à chaque prise de parole
d'ailleurs maintenant quand on regarde
toutes ses apparitions six interviews
ses prises de parole elle parle pouvoir
d'achat donc elle est mono thématiques
comme les d'eric zemmour sur le grand
remplacement parce que vous l'avez pas
dit et c'est quand même cette théorie là
qui fait sa compagne marine le pen qui a
subi un certain nombre de défections
et la dernière en date c'est quand même
celle de sa nièce marion maréchal marion
maréchal qui était ce matin sur ses news
voilà ce qu'elle dit quand elle compare
en fait
marine le pen et eric zemmour a coûté
bien je crois qu'eric zemmour
aujourd'hui à des cartes en main que
marine le pen n'a pas voilà sur le plan
politique je pense à sa capacité à citer
de rassemblement et vendent alors
exactement notamment à droite je pense à
sa capacité à briser le cordon sanitaire
et on le voit avec des déclarations
comme celle par exemple de française et
les bellamy détiennent blanc qui est
sénateur et l'air je pense à eric ciotti
également qui a dit qu'en cas de 2e tour
les appelait à vous rejoindre enfin ça y
est il votre eric zemmour choses qu'il
n'aurait jamais fait à l'égard du
rassemblement national
quand il a dit qu'il faut effectivement
se projeter dans l'après présidentielle
la recomposition de la droite ou des
droites elle est inéluctable je ne sais
pas si elle était nue est stable mais
elle est souhaitée par les régler moore
et par mario matt le sens de son
ralliement à zemmour parce qu'on peut
pas dire qu'elle sera lié à la victoire
elle le soutient à un moment où il est
plutôt en perte de vitesse donc elle est
en train de jouer la recomposition de la
droite après l'élection ne sera pas la
seule vont être nombreux sur ce terrain
là il va y avoir évidemment zemmour il
ya 20 ans marion maréchal il va ya voir
laurent wauquiez et eric ciotti donc ça
va être extrêmement complexe ça va
évidemment le résultat des législatives
va être extrêmement important
ces gens là ne joue absolument pas la
victoire il jour le coup le coup d'après
et marion maréchal est une concurrente
futur probable d'eric zemmour de laurent
wauquiez et et moussa mais dans ce que
vous dites je vous acté le fait que la
droite dont vous parliez qui était
peut-être le réservoir de voix de l'ailé
pécresse elle va s'ancrer emmanuel
macron parce que c'est intéressant dans
le vent pour la lys je pense qu'il ya
des gens à droite qui vont vouloir au
contraire
reconstituer une
une droite si tant est qu'elle ait
jamais existé qui balaye de la droite
républicaine pécresse obédience juppé à
la droite extrême
version zemmour ils vont essayer cette
recomposition et tout dépend de la
capacité du noyau du canal historique l
air
de résister à cela et ça je ne sais
absolument pas comment ça va se jouer et
ça c'est ce qui rendra
l'après-présidentielle passionnante
laurent qu'est roland cayrol mais il ya
un élément qui va être puissant pour
cette droite républicaine et il
s'appelle edouard philippe évidemment
oui il y à edouard philippe et yann
toutes et tous ces gens de droite qui
ont fini par rallier
macron président à la crau candidats et
c'est là qu'il va falloir voir parce que
chaque groupe va affluer sur les autres
et y compris moi cette histoire de
l'union des droites c'est pas si évident
que ça quand même parce que peut se dire
aussi que ça ça ne marche jamais après
tout il ya le rassemblement national qui
va s'opposer à ce sera marine le pen
elle est la seule avec ma kron a joué le
gauche et droite elle a dans son
électorat elle a changé d'électorat par
rapport à son père elle a ajouté à
l'électorat de son père un électorat
pratiquement numériquement aussi
important que celui qu'elle a dit
qu'elle avait hérité qui sont des
électeurs socialistes et communistes du
nord pas de calais voilà et elle a un
programme économique qui se rapproche
plus de la cgt que des partis d'extrême
droite c'est vrai
elle lancera pas donc faire l'union des
droites sans cette force qui reste quand
même très importante dans le pays avec
la d'électorat qui s'est fabriqué dans
ces 20 dernières années petit à petit et
puis
l'évoqué autres qui vont hériter de ce
ces républicains est-ce qu'ils ont pas
plutôt intérêt à faire c'est plutôt et
d'aller faire cette union avec le
zemmour qui quand même fait peur à
beaucoup de français et ce qu'ils
peuvent pas se dire il vaut mieux
reconstruire la droite on a cinq ans
pour repartir sur des bases jura +
macron dans cinq ans il ya peut-être une
place pour une vraie droite républicaine
donc je je je crois que cette histoire
de l'union des droites c'est pas si
évident que ça dans le paysage politique
qui vient bien frontières mais encore
étanche entre cette droite et l'extreme
seul changement est difficile de
d'imaginer un parti qui puisse regrouper
comme vous le disiez valérie pécresse et
marine le pen
j'ai dit que ces gens vont essayer je ne
comprends rien de leur capacité à
assumer leurs projets et les casiers
c'est un fantasme parce que il ya encore
quelques années il disait ump s pour
définir justement ce à quoi il
s'opposait donc il mettait les
républicains
nous mp avec le parti socialiste vous
imaginez bien que les électeurs ne sont
pas non plus idiots ils ont bien compris
que les élèves étaient très différents
voire étrangers à eux je voudrais
conclure en revenant sur la question de
l'électorat de marine le pen
effectivement sur le le taux d'
indécision parliez du socle électoral
d'emmanuel macro qui est solide est ce
que c'est le cas aussi pour marine le
pen s'est effectivement aussi le cas
pour marine le pen et c'est la hausse
est elle aussi c'est la candidate qui
arrive en deuxième position aussi en
termes de potentiel électoral donc quand
on demande aux français est ce qu'il
peut il serait possible que vous votiez
pour marine le pen est ce qui n'est pas
totalement exclue et bien l'arrêt en
deuxième position le premier c'est
emmanuel macron 42% des français nous
disent c'est pas exclu que je puisse
voter pour emmanuel macron marine le pen
c'est 33 % et la troisième qui arrive
entre les positions c'est valérie
pécresse 26% des français nous disent
c'est pas exclu effectivement que je
puisse voter pour pour elle donc je
reviens effectivement sur marine le pen
marine le pen on a quand même c'est 33%
kunis c'est possible en fait le jeune je
ne je ne l'exclus pas et c'est là encore
une fois c'est là la deuxième candidate
et de la même façon quand on voit
finalement son électorat et la façon
dont il se compose sécher
cette candidate là qu'on voit finalement
le plus de stabilité derrière emmanuel
macron merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat